our next guest is a a return guest um
i just love his passion for football and
his passion for this great show
seal team he loves everything about this
show
he lives it he breathes it he has
studied it and he's also directing part
one
of the two-hour premiere of season four
of seal team that airs tomorrow on cbs
at nine eastern time he is
david borianis how are you david i'm
good rich i got a bone to pick with you
man well oh
all right let's start with bone picking
what do you got okay
you know run rich run yes yeah you know
the
amazing work that you're doing i saw
what you did i i put it on i got no love
oh no no no no no no no i put that
i read in full gear i saw that and i put
it on my twitter feed we put it on our
twitter feed here
okay you don't see it okay i made sure
they put it on nfl network i'm you know
you're a busy man i know you're not
watching all 19 million hours of nfl
network coverage
but i really no i greatly appreciated
that no doubt i mean
you did you said last time you were here
in person pre-pandemic
you said when you do your run i'm gonna
put on the full gear and run
and you did it i mean how how much
how much weight did were you holding
those gears you know they usually have
those guys are strapped in 120 140
pounds gosh
usually that's what they usually have on
um
and that's going through conditions
whether you're swimming through it or
walking through
it so i had probably about 40 pounds
damn
40 50 pounds and you clocked and you
clocked i think still
faster than what i did
just only my the weight of the pressure
on my back
pretty much it was actually i did that
before we started shooting this season
premiere which we
ended up into uh shooting in the snow
and big bear and uh
with the dog so that was kind of
training with the dogs you kind of
kicked off the whole
training and uh with the dog with dita
in order to get her ready for
this great episode that's coming out
tomorrow fantastic david boriana is here
on the rich eisen show and since we are
buried the so-called bona pic uh let me
let me create a new one
uh by asking you that since this
premiere was shot uh months ago
uh it is not true that episode uh that
you directed
is to get the seal team to get carson
wentz out of the starting lineup that's
correct
everyone's gonna just ask about that is
uh
i i think philadelphia has just been in
a world of hurt for
a couple years now after winning a super
bowl and uh
putting up statues at the novus care
center has
been great and all but i i don't think
that they have really fully
drafted the right players to support
carson wentz i mean you can argue this
back and forth
um it's just weird to me that you you
draft a quarterback like jalen hurts in
the second round there's carson when
saying how would i have to prove myself
again and you know you kind of have that
kind of monkey on your back
kind of feeling um i can understand
where he's coming from it's kind of like
hey bravo one you got bravo two's gonna
come in and replace you he's just in the
wings waiting
but i i i don't think that that should
affect him as an athlete he should
kind of thrive in that type of
competition when it comes to
being the quarterback for the
philadelphia eagles and i don't think it
hurt aaron rodgers this year no i mean
look at the numbers he's putting up
like it's it's pretty crazy so then you
have to dig deeper and go well is this a
coaching thing and
you know where's the offensive
coordinator right i mean
i just think philadelphia has been going
around about it the wrong way as far as
their direction is concerned i mean that
team partied for a year after they won
the super bowl it was
there was a lot of champagne being
sprayed every day
and and rightfully so i mean they were
the champs but
did howie do justice
you know is there a front office
conflict with doug peterson it's like
you kind of see it all in the writing
right now and as we as fans
or as you as you know in the media and
reports you just kind of have to put out
your two cents and
and in philadelphia it doesn't it
doesn't help especially this morning on
wip i think they were saying you know
carson wentz is feeling like you know
there's rumors going around that he
doesn't like jalen hurts they shouldn't
have picked him in the second round
i mean that's just typical philadelphia
right that's typical philadelphia right
there at its best
wow you know i'll be honest i i
i if if wence does and i don't believe
it
that if once does have a problem with a
draft choice you know
it's got to be and and i i i say this
you know uh i i i don't like being
critical of younger players but it's got
to be
instead of taking justin jefferson who
has crushed it for the minnesota vikings
they took jaylen rager
who's you know was banged up and they're
still waiting for him to to
provide some sort of spark like this and
you know i'm just wondering if if
whence david david borianis and we'll
talk about seal team in a second
um it's it it seems to me i'm wondering
if once you know
out of all the narratives of last year
going into last year as you know it was
like can wence get through a season
because it had been two seasons in a row
where he had not finished and without
foals there now as the backup
yeah is it is is wence gonna gonna
be brittle and everybody got hurt around
him and he answered the bell
for all 16 weeks got the team to the
playoffs
right and and and i'm wondering if
that didn't absorb so many so many hits
in his body
that we're seeing diminishing returns
this year with everything else counting
against them
i'm i'm wondering if that might have
something to do with it i'm
i'm grasping at straws here yeah
possible i mean look he played last
night so he ran the ball a couple times
and he was pretty straight up and
taking on the defender pretty pretty
hard so he was pretty mobile his
offensive line
you know decimated been moved around a
lot jason peters what has
broken toe i know playing with broken
toe you know
john johnson's been struggling you know
you have zach earth has been out
i mean so there's a lot of pieces there
we don't have any linebackers
per se i mean are or we have darius slay
that we picked up so there was a good
pickup but dj metcalf just smoked him
last night
so you know there's no player like dj
metcalf was available philly passed on
him
so there's there's you can see the
players that are are bearing fruit right
now and then the players that aren't and
that the ones that philadelphia has
and on top of it like run the ball you
have you know you have
a great running back and for some reason
doug peterson just does not commit
committing to the run and uh his choices
last night
on fourth down were bad i mean it's just
kind of like a coach that wants to get
fired
in a lot of ways i mean you look at it
and go wow does this guy really want to
is he getting along with with you know
jeff laurie and the front office and
howie
i mean you know we don't know that but
we can only assume
and in philadelphia they want answers
they don't want people that lose and
when it gets consistent like this it
gets cold
and they get upset they're not allowed
back in the link you know that's an
issue
so there's you know philly is tough and
uh
that's just the way they are and when
you play with philly or you're under
that organization you just gotta expect
that and
you gotta have tough skin to play
whether it's in philadelphia or new york
um and go through the ups and downs and
they're
they're in a downspout right now and uh
and for all
sakes and purposes this whole nfce like
ridiculously soft
although i do like washington i think
the redskins are going to win the ice
the the old the old football team you
know
going get getting it done over the over
the thanksgiving
holiday and um you know it's interesting
i did read an article i forgot who who
wrote it in the philadelphia inquirer
wondering if
peterson wants to get fired i saw that
that was way out there in the
philadelphia media
that was part of the backdrop of this
game on monday i saw that they do
that's what they do you know you're out
in philadelphia then you're always going
to get that cheesesteak late night
and once you're past 12 o'clock and you
get that cheesesteak especially in the
winter
the ketchup gets cold so it's freezing
on the tip of the omarosa bread
come out there's a problem it thinks the
unions get upset
i love it when was the last time really
though i mean you you've got to be in
shape for seal team when was the last
time you did have one of those late
night
uh cheesesteaks i would probably a
couple years ago
okay yeah but it was during the summer
so ketchup was nice and warm
okay and i guess and so is is it whiz
wit or
wiz without with wit okay got the roll
there's plenty of you know whatever
cheesesteaks are prevalent right now
it's wherever you go
it's the only consistent thing in
philadelphia going down right david
boreanaz here on the rich eisen show so
what to expect out of
uh season four and again this is real
stuff man i know you you take pride in
in the personal and professional lives
of these uh great
uh members of seal team that you're
bringing to uh
cbs go for it i'll give you the floor
well excited i mean you know with
tomorrow's kicks off in
a way that we see jason hayes and bravo
one on top of mountain
going after the son of a major terrorist
that he killed 13 years ago so it kind
of messes with his head and
he gets separated from the team and the
dog the two of them have to kind of
survive
a little revenant feel to it and in
doing so
uh through the survival aspect of it
with the dogs is wounded
he starts having flashbacks and ptsd
moments of his past and we have some
flashbacks so
we ended the episode with him on the
mountainside with a dog and
create a lot of pain and we don't know
who makes it off that bound top so
it's an exciting start to our episode
thinking that it was going to be the
season finale for last year but then
because of covet we
wait so it becomes our premiere for this
year which production value is huge
shooting in big bear real snow real
elements
wide-angle lenses it's just as awesome
and jimmy mural of the dp who
just crushes it oscar winner guy just is
insane and
chris tulac spencer hud nut writing we
just have a
a great group of guys telling stories uh
that are really relevant
and about these characters that you know
strive to protect but also struggle so
much inside internally when they come
back home and
that's the story that we like to tell
get into the dark corners of their minds
and
exposing that and so people can see that
uh you know
they're they're worth more than what
they what they do for us out there and
that's something we have to embrace more
the real deal stuff two-hour season four
premiere of seal team again airs
tomorrow nine eastern on on cbs
uh before i let you go david um were you
uh psyched about the dodgers world
series win because
uh we have a photograph here of you
we're looking at on the screen right
here
uh a ball boy back in the day are you
are you who are you next to
like is that a amalfitano is that who
you're next to the pitching coach
yeah i had on the ron say i had the ron
say glove
look at you man it was in right field
flag and fly balls with fernando
valenzuela
tried to get under one lost it in the
sun at the vet and he was screaming at
me
so but it looks like you're locked in
though i don't know what you were
staring at
out the uh locked in well i was more
upset that my father
hired a photographer to take pictures of
me
being the fact that i didn't want to you
know i kind of wanted to play cool you
know
and i got him really embarrassed i love
to photograph this day but to this day i
look back and i go geez i was so
embarrassed
were you really you're like don't
embarrass me in front of garvey dad is
that what you want to
do i can't do that as a vet that's
ridiculous
you got to play you know what but you
got to live the part rich you gotta go
in even in eighth grade i was living it
man i
had the pine tar i had the dip i am
hanging out with
francais fernando let's go
you do look locked in there but you're
really a pissed off kid at his dad
i love that back story that is
phenomenal
all right before i let you go here let's
uh let's put it up here on the screen
we want to give you the love we're
showing it right now david there you are
there you are yeah which run there's the
dog too
there it is even the dog did it for you
it died
there you go
[Laughter]
you go brother thank you for that david
it really meant a lot
i did see it i do i do great i know he
did he just i
i love staring the pot i love it that's
what that's what philly guys do
you take care david thanks for the call
and we'll be checking out uh seal team
uh again the season four premiere
tomorrow on cbs at nine eastern time
that's david boreanaz here
on the rich eisen show fun stuff right
there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here